welcome to another Dr Sadler's honest
book reviews the book that we have today
is how to tell a joke an ancient Guide
to the art of humor it's listed here as
being Marcus Tulia Cicero but it
actually contains Cicero and quintillion
and it's translated and introduced by
Michael Fontaine published by Princeton
University press and if you've seen some
of my earlier reviews in the series you
know that this is a book in a long
series that's been coming out from
Princeton University press
how to do x y z where they take some
selections from ancient philosophy and
then they you know translate them and
publish them in a facing Pages uh
Edition that we'll talk about in a
little bit more the series is focused on
primarily books in philosophy but
philosophy understood quite broadly so
it extends to self-help and to
leadership and organizational matters
and in this case to jokes and humor and
comedy so we're going to talk about a
lot of stuff get into a good bit of
detail about the book and you know you
can decide for yourself whether this is
something that you might want to
purchase for yourself if you do there's
a Amazon link below that you can check
out it's an affiliate link so of course
I get a tiny little bit and it might be
a nice way of supporting the channel if
you want to do that so a lot to say
about this work
We Begin by talking about the three s's
the style of the work the structure of
the work and giving you kind of a
summary so why don't I do the summary
first because I think that'll lead
naturally into all of the other
dimensions of it so it's really
divided into two main sections you know
we've got
um
translations from Cicero's de oratorre
that's the first half of the book aside
from the introduction and then we have
quintillion's institutio or oratoria and
so these are being translated by the
same person who is bringing a sort of
unity to these and what is the goal here
what is this text supposed to do it's
supposed to give you some idea about at
least what some ancient thinkers thought
about the art of humor but specifically
in relation to public speaking rhetoric
oratory and there's a lot of advice
that's given in this that may or may not
be as useful today as it was in ancient
times actually some of it might be a
little bit more useful depending on
which particular thing we're looking at
so the summary you know what is the book
about humor jokes and how we can use
them and how we can classify them so we
know what we're doing when we're telling
jokes could you use this as a guidebook
to become more witty a better respondent
you know for example in public debates
or speaking I think you could that's
part of what the original goal was
um and you know it might be helpful for
for that now the style Okay so we've got
two main authors being translated by one
single translator and I am going to have
to talk a little bit later about the
difficulty which the author acknowledges
or the rather the translator
acknowledges of going from one language
and one cultural context to another with
humor it's a little bit more difficult
than say doing plain old history or
philosophy or something like that so
that's something to keep in mind it is a
facing page translation which means that
you've got the Latin on one side and the
English
corresponding to it on the other you
know everything is nicely marked so you
can tell exactly where things are it's
sort of like the lobe classical editions
except a little bit more selective not
including quite so much in the The Works
not least because you know it's fairly
large print with significant spacing the
book could probably be a good bit
smaller if they hadn't done that but
some people might appreciate that that
larger
print and what we're getting in this are
those two big blocks of text and those
two big blocks of text are giving us
essentially summaries and breakdowns and
quotations and some organization and
some ideas about what is worth thinking
about I do want to point out that in
addition to these two Big Blocks we have
a long long introduction which is a I
think actually quite good
worth reading for its own sake because
the translator is you know talking about
what they're doing in this it begins
with it the question is humor a
teachable skill or something you're born
with here's some people who actually
brought it up and then we we learn about
other authors like for example macrobius
who is quoting from this or Plutarch or
um you know later on we hear about
others as well it talks about the
formats of the the work actually both of
these Works who the speakers are and the
dialogues how the Renaissance picked
this stuff back up and then you know
gets us essentially to the present time
and there's some notes about the
translation and I'm actually going to
read just a tiny little bit of this
because this may be important for you so
styles of translation vary some are
literal others go for the gist this one
goes for the jest and it can claim a
good pedigree my job as translator
Cicero once remarked is not to be a bank
teller counting out coins for readers
it's to compensate them for the weight
in that Spirit I've racked my brains to
find equivalent words names puns
phrasing and cultural counterparts to
make the jokes as funny in English as
they are in Latin I've also changed or
suppressed details that would cause
confusion or attract undue attention if
kept in you can call it paternalism or
you can call it good comedy a comedian
limits the distractions so do I and it
he also talks here about you know having
a pedigree the first person to translate
Cicero's jokes was Plutarch and it gives
you a few examples of of that as as well
so I think that gives you a sufficient
understanding about the uh you know
style and the structure there's also a
number of notes and a very short
bibliography with some further reading
it's not a comprehensive discussion of
humor by any means but you know it'll
it'll get you started on some tracks
that you can follow out
what are some of the main ideas or
points or topics considered in this well
I've already brought up one that the
translator highlighted from the very
first sentence is comedy is humor is
making jokes something that we can teach
and learn and improve in or is it
something more like just an innate skill
so both of these authors that we're
looking at and the translator would say
that okay they're they're definitely is
some you know some people who are more
gifted others who are less so but you
can definitely
improve your capacity to tell and
perhaps even appreciate jokes by doing
some sort of training and that's
essentially what this is providing us
with now both of the authors texts are
aimed at ancient situations and it it's
a challenge to apply this to Modern
Times we're in a very different culture
you know some of the the reference might
not make as much sense or be as funny in
the present as they were back then but a
lot of this is
I don't want to say completely Universal
but certainly has stood the test of time
now there's two main
works here so what can we say about each
of them the section of Cicero's day
oratori
begins by talking about kinds of humor
and jokes discusses how to make jokes
when we need to make jokes when it can
be useful or conducive you might say for
us and there's a dialogue going on here
between the different people so I'm I'm
going to just read a little bit here
um Anthony is is talking and he says
um
you said you see you said we need to
take stock of the people the case the
circumstances so that a joke won't
compromise our Authority and it's true
Crassus really does this but this rule
applies to not making jokes when there's
no need of them what we're actually
interested in is how to use them when we
do need them as for example against an
opponent and especially how to trigger a
stupid eager lightweight witness when
the audience looks receptive to him so a
lot of this is within you could say
circumstances
where there's a there's a contest going
on right the the Law Courts for example
or the Forum are providing a lot of
examples and then there are five guiding
questions that get asked about laughter
um
so as not to keep you all waiting any
longer I'll outline the whole shebang
when it comes to laughter there are five
questions to ask what is it
where does it come from
should an orator want to make people
laugh if so how much and what are the
different kinds of jokes and then you
know the narrator or the rather the
interlocutor uh discusses each of these
in turn and one of them is going to get
um a bit more study than the others and
that's the fifth question the different
kinds of jokes and much of the rest of
this selection from Cicero's de oratori
is going to be classification of the as
it turns out many different kinds of
jokes that you can use so there's some
preliminary questions and then there's a
lot of let's let's lay it all out for
you what about the quintillion section
so
this is deeper on in the the book and uh
quintillion says that um you know he's
going to bring laughter into important
domains and he begins by saying you know
should we actually be thinking about
this and he's referencing Cicero which
is a good reason for bringing this up
and
um you know he goes through a number of
different steps and then says humor is
risky uh as Cicero says laughter has its
home and some ugliness and disgrace it's
called urbanity when you draw attention
to it and others when it boomerangs back
at the speaker it's called stupidity
laughter also seems like a minor thing
something that any stand-up comedian
street performer or idiot can get
nevertheless
it does have a certain overpowering and
conquering Force where all resistance is
futile so you know he's acknowledging
that humor can play an important role
even in domains that seem quite serious
he then goes on to consider whether we
can teach humor to other people and he
says a couple interesting things
genetics don't merely determine whether
a person is Wittier and quicker quicker
at coming up with ideas teaching really
can improve that some people just
intrinsically have a special look about
them the way they move their face such
that the same jokes don't seem as funny
when somebody else tells them and I I
think that's probably quite true but
then he says the right opportunity
though
hinges on both situations and also on
what a prior speaker says because every
quip is much more fun as a comeback than
a provocation and he's talking about
other things that make humor difficult
and he says quite interestingly there
are no practice lessons for it no
teachers now this book is giving us
practice lessons for it kind of in
outline isn't it and then he says still
nothing's ever stopped anyone from
creating instructional materials
suitable for it like mock debates that
would be genuinely funny or special
prompts to drill students in it it's the
opposite actually if we systematize them
a bitter added a bit of seriousness to
the mix one thing that could be really
useful are those cut Downs that we use
to take turns exchanging on anything
goes days at the moment they're just a
one-upping game for students having fun
so he's you know giving some
consideration to the question how much
can we actually teach about this then
we see quintillion discussing six
different
kinds or modalities of humor he says we
use a number of different names for the
same thing and if we look at them
separately each one will reveal its own
special properties and I'm not going to
outline all these I'll just mention what
they are urbanity
the Charming salty or zesty
um
uh the witty which is coming from the
word uh facetum you know whether we get
facetious from uh a joke a yokus right
and then interestingly being a jerk uh
it's he says
is obviously derived from the word to
say Dickory right and so there's there's
these six different kinds and then he
starts going into well he talks about
humor and its uses but then he talks
about sort of like Cicero did what are
the different kinds of jokes
uh what are their situations how do we
actually use them and then he'll talk
about other things so he's got this
interesting section how to get a laugh
and when the room targets who are we
aiming humor at and techniques to use so
this is again providing some guidance
for tell a joke like this in this sort
of circumstance
these are also tied in with rhetorical
categories
um quintillion as well as Cicero are
teachers of rhetoric so he talks about
brainstorming style of presentation all
of these sorts of
matters and then it goes into a lot of
different types and techniques through
most of you know the rest of the things
sort of similar to Cicero but then
there's also this appendix on urbanity
what is it to be Urbane right and he
talks about a famous poet domitius
Marcis and considers some of their ideas
in this so that's those are the main
points that's what you're going to see
discussed in this work should you choose
to get your hands on it and read it
so what did I find particularly good
about this work what can I tell you
about it that might you know lead you
towards checking it out so I I didn't
really like the introduction and there
there's a couple features of it that I
thought were quite good the short
history of these texts and thinkers it's
uh just enough it's not too much but it
gives you good guiding points for how to
think about this stuff and how we might
you know follow out that thread into our
own time as I've mentioned already
translating is a difficult business
translating humor is probably more
difficult than many other
um
types of literature that we're going to
focus on and I think that there's
there's a great discussion about just
how hard that can be by this this uh
translator Michael Fontaine and I I you
know I think that the whole thing is
quite readable which you know matters
quite a bit these are these are texts
that we typically study as academics but
I think this is great for a broader
public to you know learn a bit about
ancient humor and how we could update it
to the present it's actually funny in
parts and it's not just Cicero and
um quintillion and the people who they
bring up who are funny it's also
Fontaine in his introduction and I would
say that Fontaine himself as a
translator is contributing to the humor
by trying to find
useful equivalence
as best as he can that work in this and
I do like that pun that he had you know
I'm not going to give you the gist of it
I'm going to give you the gist of it I
think he's really trying to do that well
and the authors themselves if you've
ever read Cicero or quintillion you know
that they're worth reading in part
because they're going to give you lots
and lots of examples this is actually
just as a side note in rhetoric in Latin
sometimes they use the term copia it's
the word that we get copia from right or
Cornucopia the Horn of Plenty this is a
specific technique or organizational
method you give the reader lots and lots
of material in an organized fashion so
that they can make sense out of what
they're reading and relate the
principles to the examples and then see
how they might apply it outside of the
scope of the work itself there's also a
lot of great classification and
distinctions made in both of the texts
so
I think that could be quite helpful for
a general reader there's lots of
interesting insights and Analysis again
both on the part of the two main authors
Cicero and quintillion and also on the
part of uh fonten I would say so that
makes it a pretty strong work and I
think there's a lot to recommend this if
you are interested in the topic of humor
you know if you were going to have a
bookshelf devoted to this and you had
things like you know Berg songs laughter
or Freud's jokes on the unconscious or
you know Bach teens Rob Alay and His
World these you know treaty seas that
are more contemporary I think this would
probably deserve to be there
alongside of those it could be quite uh
useful quite quite helpful part of the
literature for you
what did I find if not bad at least
problematic about the work so I'm going
to start with a very general criticism
that I've been raising against the books
in this series uh you know having the
Latin and or in some cases Greek
and English on facing Pages sort of like
what the Loeb uh classical Edition does
you know it looks cool I don't know that
that many readers are actually going to
be checking out the original language so
you're kind of paying for a book that's
twice the size that it needs to be I
mean it it could have been done where
the English was provided on both pages
and then just you know occasional terms
are provided in in Brackets and you know
the book is because of the way it's
designed way way longer than it needs to
be I mean you can take a look and see
what the spacing that you're certainly
filling up a lot of blank space in these
pages and that's that's kind of a minor
criticism but I don't know it might be
important for some of you who are
watching this and considering whether to
get the book
one thing that I also didn't
like in the design of the book and let
me find a good page where we see this is
that the quotes by other authors are put
into
these weird kind of Blocky
things that
I understand why they might want to do
it but it just doesn't look all that
great so here is a page where they're
doing this right
for example here's how Cicero peppered
fabrica's famous getaway and so then it
it sets it out see how it's in Gray
um I you know there's many choices that
you could make as an editor about how to
lay things out I I just don't think
that's particularly good and it's
sometimes it's not really consistent at
every point I would say as well but
again kind of a minor quibble
um
occasionally the translator as the
translators admit I'm going to leave
some things out sometimes they've
actually added some things in I think a
little bit unnecessarily in ways that
could be confusing to a reader who can't
check out the Latin so for example in
talking about
um
there's this line here novious is full
of this kind of thing one's common guess
what Mr stoic if it gets cold you will
shiver but there's no mention of stoic
in there whatsoever
sapiens SI Al gabis
that's the the Latin for that there
isn't any reference to stoics so why are
you bringing that up and why is it
capitalized that's a choice on the part
of Fontaine to try to convey something
but you know given how important
stoicism is to Cicero
and in ancient times I think this is
inviting some misunderstandings on the
part of the latinless reader
so you know maybe there's a little bit
of fast and looseness there that
you know we should ask ourselves
um it's a book about humor
is this conducing to the funniness
is this helping us to understand it or
is it leading Us in the wrong direction
I think we can say that at a couple
different points the other thing that I
will say and again this is kind of a
minor criticism and I'm very very
cognizant as a translator myself about
how hard it is to translate things well
so it's tough to convey humor just going
from one contemporary language to
another or even in just English itself
we can have context where we rely upon
slang and what was funny you know the
way that people talk 50 years ago isn't
funny anymore and vice versa or across
you know various different subcultures
so going from ancient Latin to
contemporary 21st century English
there's bound to be some difficulties in
doing this
um you know I just want to give you one
example that might not translate that
well even in contemporary English
so there's a reference here we go
this is uh mattelis was drafting men for
the Army and wouldn't accept my excuse
for poor eyesight so you can't see
anything he asked actually I can I said
I can see your mcmansion from the
Escalon gate okay so you know vilon tuam
is is what is being translated here as
mcmansion and you know for me mcmansion
I know what a mcmansion is because it's
an American term that we use for these
very drab looking gigantic houses that
people build and subdivisions and they
all kind of look the same way more house
as we say than a person needs
um
would that make as much sense to other
English readers in the world
oh maybe not so maybe that's a little
too American
um you know there's a reference there
basically to McDonald's and and fast
food and then to houses and it's just
translating the word Villa so there are
some places where as a Latin reader
um I'm not entirely comfortable with the
way it's translated but again he
translated it I didn't so and I do
translate other things so I'm I'm pretty
willing to
give translators the proverbial benefit
of the doubt and I don't want to tear it
down so you notice my complaints
criticisms are are pretty trivial stuff
on the whole you know they're they're
not anything that would damn the book
right and I I'm not also damning it with
faint praise as the saying goes
all right so my final thoughts on this
you know I recommend it I don't have a
qualified
recommendation I would say if you're
interested in the topic of humor uh
considered from let's call them both
experiential empirical perspectives but
also theoretical perspectives it's a
good book you you probably want to get
your hands on it and read it through
certainly showing you how much attention
was being given to this by some rather
funny but also very intelligent people
who were concerned with education quite
broadly with society and specifically
with the force of rhetoric or oratory or
persuasive communication so I think it's
a pretty good book and I certainly
enjoyed reading through it I'm going to
keep it and read through it again some
time down the line and maybe you know do
a closer study and maybe even
incorporate some of these techniques and
jokes and ways of being a funny person
so yeah that's that's what I have to say
about it I think the translations on the
whole are pretty good I've registered my
not even complaints but more like
misgivings about a few of them but on
the whole I would say it's a it's quite
a task that
Fontaine pulled off here in translating
and then providing a great introduction
and some other resources for you about
humor and jokes